cloud spanner is a relational database
that powers
billion user products every month it's
trusted by banks
retailers and many other organizations
to support their mission critical
applications
so how do you know if spanner makes
sense for you today
we're highlighting three industries that
rely on spanner to solve challenges
reduce costs and accelerate innovation
to deliver best of breed customer
experience
stay tuned
in our last episode we covered why
spanner is a great option to hit the
optimal balance between scalability
consistency and high availability for
your database
in this episode we're going to connect
the dots to show you how spanner is
being used to solve pressing problems in
financial services
retail and gaming first up
financial services banks fintech
companies
and their regulators demand 24 7 access
to accurate information
in order to drive core operations they
use spanner in a wide range of
applications including payment gateways
and online banking payment gateways
connect purchases from many
often millions of customers to thousands
of vendors
this scale alone can make typical
databases buckle
compounding the problem all of this data
needs to be 100
consistent as payments flow through
sophisticated anti-fraud and settlement
processes
dropping a payment or double counting
would be a serious
issue spanner is also used today in
online banking to improve reliability
and enable innovation for mission
processes
such as transaction tracking and user
profile management
customer demands for new products and
modern interactive experiences have
taxed online banks databases
with last generation scale-up
technologies banks had to re-architect
their systems to scale in ways their
databases weren't designed for
the result is extra complexity and
maintenance
developers have to work around a
fragmented view of the data
while operators struggle to ensure
uptime in a stitched together system
banks and fintech innovators choose
spanner because of its industry-leading
five nines of availability zero plan
maintenance downtime
security certifications and the highest
consistency guarantees of any scale out
database
spanner allows financial services to
scale their databases regionally or even
globally
without any downtime or compromises to
the integrity or security of their data
this scale insurance means they're able
to easily accommodate
long-term growth or unexpected spikes
without painful re-architecture or
downtime
spanner eliminates complexity and
maintenance overhead by pushing
sharding and replication down into the
database
not as an afterthought to your
developers and dbas
it looks like a single database instance
that can scale on demand
spanner is also used in the red hot
gaming industry to support
real time gameplay and in-game purchases
that are driving revenues
popular game launches have become
cultural touchstones
even a niche game can attract millions
of global users at launch
who demand interactive gameplay that's
always online
this burst of high volume real-time
traffic can be
game over for common databases ensuring
play from a gamer in asia is immediately
visible to her opponent in south america
typically requires manual database
sharding in order to scale
in modern digital games database
maintenance windows are also a big risk
with global players and multiple game
franchises
it can be impossible to schedule
downtime to patch the database or
updated schema
to support new capabilities for gaming
or
any other always-on global business
spanner is fully managed and never needs
to be paused for patches backups
failover or even schema updates
using google's dedicated infrastructure
spanner guarantees consistency
and zero plan downtime even at the most
extreme scale
which translates into better gameplay
and satisfied customers
retailers face many of the same
challenges as banks and game
studios new digital channels like online
shopping with in-store pickup
digital wallet and mobile rewards
redemption present new opportunities
but also impose additional hurdles for
already stretched it organizations
retail supply chains have also become
more complex
and on demand just in time fulfillment
and dynamic pricing
and e-commerce mean that a retailer's
inventory and product catalog
must always be up-to-date and consistent
stockouts erode trust from consumers
whose alternative purchasing options are
on the rise spanner gives retailers a
consistent view of their inventory
pricing and demand across channels and
locations
without having to hack together data
stores and using the sql that developers
and analysts
already know online orders are
immediately reflected in
inventory across online and brick and
mortar stores
and warehouses across thousands of
products and hundreds of locations
if this weren't challenging enough
retail often experiences extreme
seasonal spikes like during black friday
in the past retailers over-provisioned
hardware to handle holiday peaks
but this is increasingly expensive and
inefficient
scaling on last generations databases
requires large
upfront expenses and downtime
nosql technologies claim web scale but
don't generally support the transactions
or sql that developers rely on
spanner gives retailers the confidence
that they'll be able to handle peak
periods
without large upfront costs or
maintenance overhead
elastic scaling allows them to expand
regionally or globally in a single click
later they can scale back down paying
for only what they use without missing a
beat
so there you have it a dip into the
benefits of availability consistency and
scalability
in finserv gaming and retail
high availability means you get an
industry-leading five nines uptime
and never have to work around plan
maintenance again
get the strictest level of consistency
of any distributed database
without sacrificing scalability for
operational workloads
and scale out and back in as needed to
avoid costly excess capacity
while handling unpredictability this
video
is just a sampling of the many
industries and use cases where spanner
helps companies solve problems
and grow their business so if you're
curious to learn more
follow the links in the description
below for additional information
thanks for joining us today and stay
tuned for more episodes of spanner
database unlimited